welcome back to another Python tutorial
with simply learn I'm Angelique and
today we will be looking into Python
scripting so what is scripting scripting
is writing programs to automate the task
and Python by itself is a scripting
language so what this means is that the
lines that you write the code lines they
are interpreted rather than compiled so
they are executed at runtime so in this
tutorial we look at a few libraries
which demonstrate the scripting feature
of Python very clearly
other than that we'll also look at a few
libraries which demonstrate its runtime
behavior so let's begin I will be coding
on Python today and the first library
that we look into is the OS library
which stands for operating system so to
use the OS library first we need to
import it so C import OS now in here I
will have two functions I'll just
demonstrate two of the most common
functions that you can utilize from the
OS library first one is to extract the
current working directory create a
function and I have a variable CWD which
stands for current working directory now
this variable will store the return
value from a function which retrieves
the current working library so you say
OS dot yet CWD and that is it one line
and you have your present directory
stored in a variable
CWD so I'll print this out and that's
our first function so out here I call
the function so now we can run our
program so this is our current directory
can see the users within the user my
particular username and pie chart
projects slash demo is this particular
project under pycharm okay so that is
our first function let's have a look at
the second one now I will demonstrate
how you can retrieve the path of a
particular file so create another
function here under this function I'll
pass a file name now in here have
another variable
I say path which holds the value of the
path that this file is stored in and to
achieve that you say oh s dot path dot
but which stands for absolute but now
you know there are two types of parts
there's the absolute and the relative
path name the absolute path name is it
gives the pathname right from your C
Drive or D Drive whichever drive it
belongs to so the relative path name is
the path respective to our current
working directory now I'll have a
variable file name out here which will
hold the name of my file whose path I
need to find out so I see sample dot txt
and then I'll pass this file name to my
function file path and that's it now
let's run our code okay so we have not
printed the value out let's do that
print paths run your code again the
first function that we call is to
retrieve a current working directory and
the second function is to retrieve the
path of this file sample dot txt and
this is the right path this is exactly
where I stored my file so all is good so
those are the two most common functions
that you use with the library or the
module OS there are quite a lot more
which you can definitely check out so
next we look into the time module so as
usual first import the module now before
I show you a few functions in the time
module you need to understand what it
book is so first January of the year
1970 is the starting point of a certain
timeline and eBook time is basically the
number of seconds that passed since
first January of 1970 so to get your
iPad I'm use the function time dot time
off and I'll store the value of this
function returns the epoch time and I'll
store it in a variable PPC filling that
out so that's the number of seconds that
has passed as of right now since first
January 1970 now obviously this has no
meaning to us so what we do is we'll
convert this to a format that means
something to us and for that purpose we
use the function local time so I create
a variable local time and use the
function local time to which you pass
the e
available now print out local time so as
you see here now we actually have
numbers that make sense to us we are in
the year 2019 the third month which is
March date is 18 12 hours 42 minutes 47
seconds so this is something we can
actually decipher now again this is a
structure it's not in our traditional
formatted weight so if you want to
extract certain information from this
structure you can easily do it saying
local time let you use the variable and
then just use these keys in here to
extract that particular value for
example I want to extract the year so I
see TM under school year print that and
you see here the year alone is extracted
now if I want the entire thing to be
displayed in a more formatted way that's
exactly what we have the function C time
for that is it print and use a function
C time again to this you need to pass
the epoch value that's EPC run our
program so now you see we have it in a
move formatted wait Monday March 18th so
we even got the day of the week in here
so those are the basics things you can
do with the time module let's move on to
our next module so the next module we'll
look at is the SMTP module now just like
HTTP SMTP is also protocol this is a
protocol for sending emails so it stands
for Simple Mail Transfer Protocol so
first we import SMTP SMTP live now in
this demo what we'll be doing is of
course we'll be sending out an email so
we'll send an email to someone's email
id through Python
now obviously Python itself cannot send
an email out what you have to do is
you'll be accessing a domain so you will
give the username and password for this
domain and you'll put in commands here
such that it automates the process of
sending a mail from that particular
domain to another email ID so first we
need to set a domain and a put and for
that we use a function SMTP Lib dot SMTP
and the first so the sticks two
arguments the first
document is a domain name now the domain
name is basically like if you're using
Gmail it will be smtp.gmail.com if
you're using hotmail it would be
smtp.mail.yahoo.com and the second
argument is the port number which is
generally five eight seven now five
eight seven is the standard port number
according to the standard encryption
standard which is TLS now that you have
set a domain and the port number the
next thing you need to do is make these
servers communicate with one another
that is basically the sender server
telling the receiver server hi am
present here and the receiver server
gives an appropriate response now in
here we'll be using SMTP dot e H ello
instead of H P Double L o that is
basically just an extended version of
hello it acts a few additional features
to your SMTP now before that we need a
variable into which will store the
object returned by this function so I'll
have SMTP obj so that SMTP is the object
through which we'll be referencing our
domain and port number so now you say
SMTP obj dot eh ello
now the next thing we do is we put our
SMTP in the TLS mood so for that we use
the function start TLS so as I mentioned
before guys the sports number is a
standard port number for TLS so now it
must be clear why we are using this
particular port number it's because we
are using the TLS connection so you say
start okay so now a connection setup
account through which we'll be sending
out the email so you say SMTP obj dot
log in and now you pass two parameters
in here the first is of course the email
ID and that is followed by your password
so to create our file first we need to
import the iOS package and in particular
we need to import path library from the
OS package now create function under
this function I'll be passing the path
at which I'll create my new file so now
before you create the file you actually
check if the file is already present see
say if not but dot is file test so
you're passing the destination here to
this function dot is fine and if your
file is already present then this
portion of the code will be skipped
because our entire program is for
building because the entire purpose of
our program is to build a file which we
do not need to do if it already exists
now in here you see open this comma W so
guys this function actually returns true
only if this file is present and this
particular path is actually a file so
suppose this destination whatever passed
a test is present but it's a folder on a
file will still enter this particular
block and so in your what you do is you
open this folder in write mode and say F
dot right welcome to Python so let's
assume destination was a folder and not
a file you enter this block here a file
is created which is opened in the right
mood and within that file you enter the
content welcome to pythons cryptic now
you are ready to close the file
now outside here I'll assign the path to
destination so this is the path guys I
want to create this file sample dot txt
under this path so basically along with
the path name where you're creating your
finally also pass the filename and then
you call this function create file
passing test and once your file is
created you can just print out file
created right okay now let's now we need
to run a code then we don't need a input
from the user so we say print so we
print file created now let's run a code
according to the statement here there is
no error our program executed completely
and created a file so now let's check if
this actually worked so I go to my
desktop this is the folder where sample
should have been created and yes it is
we'll open the file and as you can see
the content two matches so we were
successfully able to automate the
creation of a file so the first argument
is
the email ad
so you have the email ID within quotes
put it within single quotes and then
your second is the password for this
particular ID and that's my password so
with these credentials your SMTP will
are basically login to your account and
then use the services of this account to
send to send an email
now the next function that will be used
now the next function that we'll be
using is the one that basically sends
your email out so that's called send
mail and in here you'll put in your
to-and-from email ids okay next is the
ID that we are sending the email to next
is he from ID I'll be sending an email
to the ID
anj to simply learn again gmail.com now
the third argument to this function is
the message that will be actually
sending so I'll be sending a very short
message here the first thing you enter
is the subject and the subject would be
SMTP check and then to move on to the
next line which is basically the body of
your message put in /n this is a test
email and that's it that's the body of
my message with the subject preceding it
and the and the last thing we need to do
is we will quit the SMT connection so
once your mail sent out we'll close the
connection this term needs the program
let's now run this code so programs run
now
to check if this actually worked we need
to go open our account at PNG to Sabrina
and check if this particular message is
present in our inbox so guys this is the
mailbox that I send the email from and
this is the one that I sent the email to
as you can see here anj to supply lon
and here is the message which has been
sent so we checked out three libraries
in python the OS library the SMTP and
the time library next we'll check out a
few programs which determine things at
runtime so now I'm going to write a
function func 1 and this function will
receive a few arguments I'll fill in the
space later
now all this function does is it prints
out the various arguments that it
receives so suppose the arguments are
stored in I and what you pass here is
also I so you pass a number to this
function and this function prints out
that number so out here we'll be calling
the function and passing a value to it
zip 10 now what if I want to pass a
varying number of arguments so say 10 20
30 for this particular run and maybe the
next run I want to pass four arguments I
want to pass 42 so how do we make this
function flexible enough that it accepts
any number of arguments and prints these
out that is where we have a RGS arcs
come in so when you put this within the
brackets what happens is that your
function will take any number of
arguments that you pass to it and store
it in the variable args so now to print
out each value that's passed to this
function you take a for loop and you
iterate that over arcs and then one by
one you can print each of these values
out so let's run this program now and as
you see 10 20 30 40 each of them have
been printed out in a separate line and
the beauty with this function is you can
change the number of values that you
print in fact you can even give in
different types of argument so I have
all integers here followed by a string
and law works so that is where you use
the variable arcs now similarly we have
another variable which is used in this
argument space which is called quacks
so that kW a RGS and you always precede
this with two stars two asterisks so so
far we looked at how a function can
accept variable number of arguments now
we look into how the function can do
this while accepting the arguments as
values to labels so what I mean here is
instead of just passing 10 20 30 what if
I want to pass a equal to 10 B equal to
20 C equal to 30 and again the number of
such pairs could vary so in that case we
have arcs for the very
but and quacks for the label part so
what you do here in the similar manner
you'll have a for loop which will
iterate through works and we want to
extract every item in it so we say items
and print out I run this code and as you
can see here so you get all the pairs
printed out so we saw how Python allows
the function to determine the number of
arguments it receives at runtime instead
of it being fixed beforehand itself now
let's move on to another program which
demonstrates automation and that is
creation of a file so this is one of the
most common and the most basic things
that you come across when you're
learning scripting not just in Python
but any language so so far we saw how a
function work we have a function name
and within it we have some code to
perform a certain function now functions
in Python can also be nested and that is
what we look at now so I'll first create
a function func one and in here I have a
variable C X which is equal to ten and
within this function I'll create another
function so that will be the nested
function for two and two front two I'll
pass X and within funk - I'll just
increment X by one and return this value
so here's a thing now within function
one we need to have a call to function
to see say funk - and you pass X to it
and out here we'll call function once a
result equal to func one print out the
value of result so what happens here is
you're calling the function func one
control goes in here X is assigned the
value 10 and over here there's a
definition for fog - but right now it
skip it moves onto this return line now
in the return line you're basically
returning funk - so what that does is it
will call function - along with the
argument X and function to returns X
plus 1 so where will this value be
returned of course it will be returned
to the statement from where the call is
made so that is still within function 1
and that means function 1 will return
the value that function 2 is returning
so what we have in result would be 10
plus 1 which is 11 let's now run this
code so as you see here 10 plus 1 in
is what's fast that is how nested
functions were now why are nested
functions important they are important
to understand the concept of how
functions can also be passed as an
object in Python and why we would do so
so I'll delete this entire code create a
function func 1 once again and in here
I'll print this is first function so
that's func 1
now within function 1 I'll have my
second function the nested function and
within the nested function I'll try it
out this is the nested function and out
here I'll have a third function which
I'll call the outer function which will
print out this is the outer function now
what I can do here is instead of
directly making a call to outer function
so sometimes what happens is you do not
want to make a direct call to a
particular function you want to make a
direct call to a function a and through
function a you want to call a function B
or C so for that what you do is you make
a call to Frank 1 and as an argument to
func one you've asked another function
name as an object so I pass out of func
so as you see here guys outer funk is
essentially a function when I'm passing
this function as an object to func 1 so
func one will receive this function I'll
show that in a variable called func
may be called func will also be passed
to our nested function and within the
nested function will make a call to this
passed function and of course finally
this turn statement where we will be
calling a nested function let's now run
this code our outer function was not
call and that's because we don't put
these parentheses here which does not
really make it a call statement let's
run this code now and as you see our
three functions were called but through
a call statement for just one so we just
called our outer function func one
passed the other outer function as an
argument to this and that took care of
executing all the three functions that
we have this kind of a situation does
not come handy very often but in certain
applications where you need to decide
which function needs to be executed at
runtime then
having the capability of passing a
function name as an object comes really
helps we saw how you can create
functions at runtime
now Python also allows you to create
classes at runtime so let's check that
out now the term for creating class at
run time is called Factory so what you
do here is you have to basically create
the skeleton I'll just write down the
basic description for all your possible
classes so you'll mention the class that
it inherits from and the attributes
associated with this classes but you do
not create it you just give that sort of
definition and then later you'll have
certain expressions to evaluate which
class is to be created depending on
certain situation so let's begin
creating the definition for our classes
so my first class would be a base class
of course we say type base class and
this will inherit from the mother of all
classes which is the objects class and
following this you'll have list of all
the attributes associated with this
class so I have no attributes associated
with my base class now the second class
I create c1 will inherit from my base
class which is B add with this class c1
will have an attribute named Val
associated to it too which will assign a
value 5 now my third class c2 will be
above the same thing as c1 just that
this time my attribute value will have a
different value 10 just so we can
differentiate between the two and of
course our class name would be c2 now
we'll have a function say def class
creator and to this I'll pass a variable
say pool now if the variable is true you
say return c1 and that will essentially
create your class C 1 else return c2
which will create class c2 now outside
here I'll call the class creator
function and I'll call it with both the
values true and false so we can see the
difference now of course this just
creates a class so to extract an
attribute value which is how we'll be
able to differentiate between the
creation of the both classes say dot
attributes name just Val in our case and
in a similar manner we call class
creator again but
them with folds shrug the value so let's
run the code now so as you can see your
guys first semi past true to class
creator and if it is true it's creating
class c1 which is this and that has the
value five associated with attribute Val
slowly when we pass false
it creates c2 just the value 10
associated with the attribute value that
is how Python allows you to create
classes even during runtime so now that
we looked into that we are back to our
nested functions or program in which we
call functions as objects now suppose I
want to call this outer function alone
now the question is is this the only way
of calling the outer function within the
func one what I mean is front one is
basically your wrapper function right
now and every function that's called
through func one comes inside this so I
want to call all the functions in the
same manner in the same serial as before
but is there an easy way to do this well
yes there is this is where decorators
come handy so just on top of outer fun
if I say at func one the way this allows
me to call outer object through func one
but just with this one statement in this
format so I just say out of func but now
that I have added decorator of func one
although I'm calling out of front it
will be called through func one just as
before let's run this good and as you
see here your func one has been called
first and outer funkhouser's been passed
as an argument to func one so that is
what decorators basically do they allow
you to change the operation or the
functionality of a function now this is
just one use case for a decorator
decorators are also used a lot to
differentiate between static and class
methods so that will be our next program
now both class method and saturd method
are bounds the class the main difference
between both of them being that a class
method can actually change the state of
a class while a static method is not
allowed to do so but here we are not
looking into what static and what class
methods are but how you can specify them
so
that purpose first I'll create a class
demo and I'll have two methods in here
my first method add one should take the
argument X and return X plus one and my
second method is add two which again
will take X and return X plus two now I
want my first method to be a class
method and the second to be a static
method now before we put in the
decorators one thing you need to
remember is the class method always has
sell fast as an argument to it while a
static method will not have this
argument self so we remove that now how
do you specify which method is class and
static that is where decorators come in
you simply have to say at the rate class
method and that will define the first
method as a class method similar way at
the rate static method and it's done
that's how you define both of them now
to call class and static method as I
mentioned earlier your class method is
bound to the class so you can just say
print off class name is demo so demo dot
add one pass ten there that's good
enough now our second which is a static
method is also bound to a class but to
be more specific it's bound to the
object of the class so you can directly
say demo dot add two you need to first
create an object of demo and then
through the object you call a static
method so if you're a programmer you
know this is how static methods are
always called especially in Java where
we really take advantage of this feature
so create an object of demo and then use
obj call your static methods at don't
pass 10 in there and there you go that's
how you differentiate between class and
static methods let's run the program
there's an arrow here which is I made a
small spelling mistake it's capital o
run the code now so the first function
which is a class method increments x
value by one so that's 11 and a second
method add to Gabe's 12 the next thing
we will be looking at is simple choice
with Python now for that we'll be using
a module quality kinter so let's import
that port ttk which is only that
particular library we need from this
particular package sorry it's deacon
term not TT kindda now first we
to create an object of tkinter type so
this is the instantiation of an object
now first thing we need to create a
flame so a flame is like this top level
object and all the widgets that you will
be adding to the frame will be organized
in a block format that's why we have the
frame and to this you obviously pass
your T key object those are the first
two basic things now we are ready to
create our widget so here I'll be
creating a very simple GI which has a
click Me button and a label it does not
really perform anything this is just to
show you a basic demo on tkinter you can
explore this further there are a lot of
materials online so first thing we will
be creating a label so for the label of
course the label would be a text so
we'll have a variable label text which
will be initialized to some value of the
type string Val so why we are not simply
giving the value here it's because when
we're creating widgets we often want to
change the text that appears or in some
cases the text is given by the user and
we need to accept that so the only thing
we can specify there is the type of the
value that is given by the user or the
type of the value that will appear on
the widget so this is where we mentioned
the type so our type would be string ver
now we'll create a label object so we
say label and it'll be within our frame
and what will appear as this label the
text that will appear here that's what
we need to specify so we say text
variable and label text okay so I forgot
to import some libraries so I will just
import the entire ticket to package here
okay so we created a label now we can
give a value to this label text to give
a value to label text you see label text
dot set and in yo I'll enter my string
this is a label now a second widget
would be a simple click Me button so
button equal to button and the button
will be within our frame and the text
that will appear on the button would be
click me and that's it so that's all the
widgets we are having here now every
bridget is put into a block format
including the frame so for that we use
the PAC function there are other formats
too
and various functions to take care of
these for example if you see labeled odd
grid and button odd grid the widgets
would be put in a table like format so
now that all our widgets are inserted
into a frame we can call the main loop
so what is the main loop now once
everything for application is created
and you say let's go let's execute this
application that's when you call the
main loop this creates an infinite loop
so your program runs and it's running an
infinite loop until the user terminates
it
so over here we are basically displaying
user interface there for main loop is
the essential feature that your GUI
should have you cannot have a GUI
without running your main loop now let's
run this program so as you see your guys
this pop-up appeared this is the label
click me of course a button is clickable
but it does not do anything we didn't
add any functionality to it now see as I
said before main loop puts your program
into an infinite loop until the user
interferes with this execution so your
loop is still running it will run for as
long as you do nothing you don't touch
this now to terminate this the user
needs to go ahead and close it like that
so that is GUI with Python so guys
that's pretty much it we have covered
most of scripting with Python if you
have any doubts regarding this please
post them in the comment section below
and we'll definitely get back to you to
know more on Python you can check out
our other videos which include Python
programming and Python tutorial so stay
tuned to our channel if you like this
video please hit the like button also
subscribe to our channel if you have not
yet so keep learning and see y'all next
time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here